[Música]
semillas de maíz frijol ají
pero no de cualquier tipo
son semillas nativas que han sido
cuidadas y custodiadas por los pueblos
indígenas de colombia durante
generaciones
algunas estuvieron a punto de
desaparecer
pero ahora se reparten a nuevas manos
indígenas para que las siembran en sus
territorios
es la semilla humana si la semilla
humana la semilla de la naturaleza la
semilla animal animal la semilla de todo
el universo si el universo todo es
semilla creo que es una manera de
pervivencia y de mostrar el origen que
nosotros tenemos como pueblos indígenas
un origen que igual que estas semillas
también ha vivido bajo amenaza
pero que los pueblos indígenas se
proponen recuperar en este congreso de
la organización nacional indígena de
colombia la única
cada cuatro años durante tres días se
reúnen más de 1000 personas que llegan
desde cada esquina del país que alberga
más de 100 etnias distintas
así eligen a sus representantes y
deciden conjuntamente cómo luchar por
supervivencia
para gabriel este compromiso está en el
pop oro su objeto sagrado
y nosotros le llamamos urbana y scan que
representa el símbolo de los árboles
eso es cara cucha de de mar
unas palabras que el pueblo wiwa usa
desde tiempos inmemoriales
también sería que dentro de ese pacto de
volver al origen
desde los consejos mayores
o de los consejeros mayores y de
nuestros mayores
se trabaje una política de relevo
generacional enmarcado en ese tag
para que la juventud
de las comunidades indígenas en este
caso del pueblo igual pueda caminar
sobre ese camino oriental de ese
conocimiento propio
un camino que muchas veces es pedregoso
más de la mitad de la población indígena
en colombia vive en pobreza además su
defensa del territorio suele ponerlos en
la mira de los grupos armados en el país
lo que quería
en 2020 47 líderes indígenas fueron
asesinados según la ong colombiana in
the path
es por eso que toque era habla así
volver al origen es una forma de
resistencia de lucha de pervivencia y
ante todo que no hay exterminio para
nosotros entonces es una forma también
de decir nosotros estamos aquí y
nosotros somos de esta manera y a
nosotros nos va a tocar ya que nos están
asesinando nos están matando vamos otra
vez a retornar hacia adentro
lo que era lo hace así vistiendo las
ropas y el arte tradicionales de los
embera y las agua es la forma de cuidar
y protección hacia nuestro cuerpo
espíritu y hacia nuestros ancestros una
forma de comunicarnos a través de los
sueños
pero también reivindicando las voces de
las mujeres en el congreso
eso de que nosotros como pueblos
indígenas hablemos de dualidad de
paridad de complementariedad eso quiere
decir que lo femenino y masculino tiene
que caminar en conjunto y es por ello de
que eso de que es pacto para volver al
origen tiene que ver con las seis
mujeres que ahorita están saliendo y es
histórico
toque era se refiere a las seis mujeres
que formarán parte del consejo de la
únic y que harán que por primera vez
este sea un órgano paritario
una de ellas es viviana suárez de la
etnia muisca
para esta consejera el patriarcado llegó
con la colonización no podemos tampoco
olvidar ni perder de vista que si bien
somos pueblos milenarios originarios el
impacto de occidente sobre nuestras
culturas ha sido muy grande y en ese
sentido pues también
como se arraigó el machismo en nuestras
culturas entonces hoy reconfigurar nos
nuevamente repensarnos y llevar ese
pensamiento de volver al origen
significa hoy queremos este paso
importante de la representación de las
mujeres porque
defiende que todavía se deben valorar
más a las mujeres indígenas
sin ellas y sin las semillas que ellas
siempre para las próximas generaciones
no hay futuro